and that was it purpose reflect think
about it you live you die in between a
lot of drama and it's a test of life
past the test of life and God Almighty
has the ultimate reward it's more
commodious than any flat villa luxury
palace it's Jenna paradise and you got
to work hard for it plant seeds of
goodness because good breeds good and
when you do good you feel good and it's
all built on that pure monotheism so ask
the creator for guidance and then you
shall receive but if you don't ask how
you're going to receive pick up the
Quran and read it it's not going to hurt
you you can get one for free 1 800 662
Islam and before you learn Islam from
someone who's full of hate spewing hate
I mean you did the right thing you tuned
into the Deen show and you got a
different perspective and this will only
enlighten you it will only open your
mind and your heart and even at the end
if you don't agree with Islam the
message at least now you had come you
had investigated you have sat with some
Muslims and you'd see that what you've
been taught is actually something that
is not true but you've actually opened
your mind you've been humble enough
because at the end what will happen if
you follow someone of hate you end up
just feeling more hate the heart girls
of hate and you just become bitter and
angry but at the end what happens you go
in like the gentleman did in Arizona
what struck me the most honestly was
when I took a minute to actually talk to
some of the Muslim people to find out
you know they are just like me and I am
uneducated on their religion you know I
could easily make as many mistakes
judgment calls as any other person out
there but when I took a second to sit
down and listen to them and actually
enter their mosque in going and watch
some of their prayers it was a beautiful
thing and he sat with the Muslims he
came in there had a totally different
perspective and then the heart softens
and maybe even got a new friend so this
is what we need to do we need to go
ahead and build these bridges we need to
communicate with our brothers in
humanity share this with your neighbors
share this with your friends and
continue to tune in here to the Deen
show we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you